bonjour bonjour et bienvenue sur canal
tv en ce début mai d'aller 2007 et nous
recevons un invité spécial c'est nicolas
giffard bonjour nicolas bonjour stéphane
alors on va te présenter pour ceux qui
te connaîtraient pas encore vu que tu
sois un des plus peut-être des plus
connus des joueurs d'échecs les plus
connus en france
alors tu as été champion de france alizé
soixante dix noms oui une fois et dans
les années 80 donc deux fois dont une
fois à 18 81 2 et quelques semaines deux
années de mondial de foot voilà donc un
des premiers grands maîtres mais trop
foncée des poux devaient être français
2e après eric après et kate un ami
d'ailleurs oui
donc quand on peut dire que tu fais
partie des pionniers en fait du
professionnalisme vous avez vous des
dinosaures dinosauria plus qu'il ya
quatre ans
non mais l'équipe de france disons de la
fin des années 70 ça a été la première à
obtenir des résultats
disons respectable depuis
en fait la disparition d'ali keane parce
qu'après l'équipe de france était
composée de joueurs qui jouaient très
très peu et avec jean-luc serait aldo
haïk
il y avait aussi didier c'est l'os on
avait plus déjà de pratique et ce qui
nous avait permis aux olympiens de ne
pas être ridicule
par exemple en 78 à buenos aires on
avait fait nul contre la yougoslavie de
partout on avait battu la bulgarie on
avait eu des moments des bourreaux du
temps s'était écoulé à la fin mais
c'était c'est l aventure extraordinaire
on n'était pas au niveau de l'équipe de
france actuelle bien entendu qui
terminent aux olympiades dans les dix
premiers pays
oui bien sûr vivants d'autant plus qu'à
l'époque on avait l'avantagé d'affronter
l'urss qui n'était qu'un seul pays
or maintenant oui il ya l'ukraine 4 et 5
ans plusieurs il ya dix pays de passer
équipe de passer de l'arménie championne
olympique bing alors qu'à l'époque il y
avait ma d'art mini - enfin il y avait
une arménie mais qui faisait part comme
avérés c'est sûr alors il ya eu cette
histoire là piccioni un peu du
professionnalisme échec premier maître
international et aussi on peut dire une
belle carrière d'écrivain tu as écrit
énormément de livres mais j'ai écrit
beaucoup de livres et puis aussi j'ai
beaucoup écrit
ces cinq dernières années pour les
éditions atlas sous forme de fiches
rangés dans des classeurs en effet 1440
j'ai quitté un peu les livres pour ça
c'était une expérience très intéressante
et puis ça va bien marcher parce qu'au
début il était prévu que moins de 1000
fiche et puis le succès alors si ça
dérange car il ya un vrai potentiel et
chic et 1,37 exploiter ou est ce qu'il
ya c'est que l'amateur d'échec et
passionné en règle générale ils achètent
beaucoup plus de publication que
l'amateur de pêcher à la ligne n'en fait
pour la paix xavi bien sûr il ya une
espèce de volonté de d'avoir tout le
matériel possible pour faire des progrès
les livres sur les ouvertures qui sont
vraiment des choses complètement obtus
pour n'importe qui qui s'intéressent
paraît vraiment aux échecs et bien pour
le celui qui commence à faire les
tournois c'est vraiment ils ont
l'impression en tout cas que c'est ce
qu'il faut posséder pour faire des
progrès alors les bouquins d'échec même
en anglais même sur des sous variantes
se vendent à un nombre respectable
d'exemplaires et donc ça c'est dû au
fait que donc le match en échec en
général quand il aime il adore alors
qu'on vient de vivre à nikolaïev aragon
je sais plus
un peu plus d'une dizaine il ya eu des
rééditions et alors il ya un best seller
absolu c'est le guide des échecs qu'elle
a aussi les échecs quoi il est un bon
accueil en 93 et il est question d'en
faire une actualisation d'ailleurs
bientôt
et oui bah il s'est vendu un peu moins
de quarante mille exemplaires c'est un
score très honorable nombre d'écrivains
même je dis rien c'est qu'on a bénéficié
du prestige de la collection la
collection de bouquins par exemple tout
ce qu elle sort elle va au moins un
exemplaire dans les librairies public
elle a libéré une commune et l'acceptent
château moins un exemplaire de n'importe
quel livre de la collection il ya donc
il ya déjà ça qui assure qu assure un
minimum de vente minimum et puis bon il
a été bien accueilli et je dois dire
j'étais content c'est un livre aussi
qu'elle a une particularité c'est qu'il
est très très souple avec du papier
bible et quand on le pose sur une table
il reste ouvert à la page oui ça c'est
très important on a va surveiller à tous
à l'arc page la plus pratique c'est un
peu ça c'est un peu la bible des
accompagnateurs de zinc à l'histoire du
jeu ouais ouais ça arrive qui a été
conçu pour comporter tous les aspects du
jeu aussi bien à l'initiation au départ
salle et d'initiation que l'histoire des
compétitions
que les femmes parties les ouvertures
les championnes du monde d'échecs est
champion du monde les champions du monde
l'histoire des champions il ya toutes
les parties de championnat du monde avec
un résultat décisif il ya tous les
résultats les plus grands tournois
favoris il a essayé ce livre d'être
somme complète en faire une sorte
d'encyclopédie quasi complet là bien sûr
donc quand on essaye d'être complet on
n'arrive jamais à être parfaitement
disséqués
chaque chapitre donc on est obligé aussi
un peu de survoler des domaines qu'on
voudrait approfondir mais y'a pas la
place alors on va montrer ses
inconvénients
on va montrer un des livres de nicolas
giffard c'est le dernier en date
oui c'est un livre de l'an 2003 il est
sorti en 2001 sans exercice pour vous
préparer au tournoi tome 3 voilà c'est à
dire que ce sont 100 exercices qui sont
un peu plus difficiles comme le titre
l'indiqué on voit déjà que ça s'adresse
à des gens qui font des tournois plus
difficile que ce qu'il y avait eu dans
le tome 2 est dans le tome 1 qui était
aussi son exercice avec la particularité
que les exercices sont sur la page de
droite et la solution est juste derrière
et pour voir la solution n'y a pas
besoin d'aller à la fin du livre mais il
suffit juste de tourner la page
un peu comme un bolide de moby fischer
alors et celle d'amis tels je connais
pas
robin fisher teachers chelsea l'a fait
de livres en fait je m'étais inspiré
d'un livre de ian d'sa est morte qui ça
plaise baisse nous
à l'origine c'était bien mais en
allemand je crois qu'il était rédigé et
rigide avez vous même le traduire
et puis en deçà et hortes ont rompu leur
amitié
ils ont jamais pu s'entendre pour
autoriser la traduction dans une autre
langue donc il ya un livre moi je
conseille à tous ceux qui peuvent se
procurer mais c'est pas facile comme
justement les deux protagonistes se sont
fâchés il ya plus de rééditions et the
death nouveautés vraiment un très bon
bouquin alors ce que ça monte des
positions assez ordinaire et avec et la
connaissance du jeu convient de ça et
l'ordre de grand maître vraiment très
bon pédagogue il arriva à montrer la
finesse des possibilités dans une
position qui al'air ordinaire il montre
des choses qu'on ne remarque pas quand
on est un joueur faible et il faut
quelquefois trouver le meilleur goût
d'autrefois à répondre à la question qui
est mieux et quelquefois y at il une
défense alors on cherche on cherche on
tourne la page on vers la solution mais
non il n'y avait pas de descente des
fonds si vous étiez massacrés
c'est fait d'une manière qui ressemble
beaucoup à la réflexion qu'on a pendant
une vraie partie de tournoi c'est à dire
que y'a pas forcément quelque chose de
très brillant a trouvé ça peut être un
coup à ses origines arabes matisse mais
voilà et je vais ça s'adapte très bien
aux joueurs on s'est tiré la braderie
1800 et 2000 qui veut
approfondir sa compréhension notamment
du milieu de partie c'est surtout
orientée sur la compréhension de
position de milieu de partie on va
remontrer sept derniers ouvrages de
nicolet giffard à cet exercice pour vous
préparer au tournoi alors cette ce livre
ou alors est aussi le guide d échec si
vous faites partie des rares joueurs
d'échecs et même des rares français
peut-être même à pas avoir ce livre le
guide des échecs le best-seller absolu
des échecs en france dans votre
bibliothèque
eh bien nous vous invitons à vous le
procureur on peut les trouver ou dans
toutes les librairies je suppose nac nac
ça c'est à la fnac et son nom toujours
et sur internet on peut les commander
sur les librairies online style alapage
amazon ça y est aussi quoi voilà donc
procurez-vous le guide des échecs ou le
dernier livre données commis chez farce
en exercice pour vous préparer au
tournoi si vous préparez un tournoi avec
un bon expert de l'écriture chicken en
france
voila voila giffard je l'avais fait en
collaboration avec jacques hellbilly
chaque mbida est aussi tout à fait qui
est un joueur donc faro car aucun il
adoube majorité d'ailleurs je joue pour
l'équipe du maroc
c'est un très bon joueur qui a une
grande combe connaissance des ouvertures
par exemple qui avait été seconde en de
hamdi ou en lettres marocains tout à
fait et qui m'a trouvé
des exemples très instructif comme
exercice dans la pratique ça je croise
un expert aussi de la varende et quatre
pions de l'estonienne oui également est
un expert de bugs gammon très joueurs
aussi chaque mbilia co auteur de ce
traité sans exercice pour préparer au
tournant voilà alors on va venir
maintenant l'actualité nicolas c'est le
tournoi chorus grand tour un chorus vic
en bigorre qui suit ça sur internet
évidemment alors on peut suivre ça
aujourd'hui sur les serveurs online
notamment on en parlera de 10cc jesse fm
évidemment est aussi pitch est simple le
site et voilà on peut le suivre sur
internet et toi je suis évidemment de
ces grands événements tu es toujours
aussi passionné d'échecs que ya 40 ans
ou qu'il ya trente ans et c'est très
intéressant parce que kasparov a pris sa
retraite au printemps 2005 et depuis
c'est la lutte pour le remplacer pour
être le vrai numéro un
on a pensé que topalov allait être celui
qui allait remplacer kasparov et puis il
a perdu contre chronique
donc oui l'eau il est toujours en tête
topalov mais il ya un nombre qu'il
talonne et akrami qui est l'officiel
champion du monde qui a la troisième
place donc il ya une espèce de l'utla
pour l'hégémonie mondiale qui est pas
encore bien défini on ne sait pas qui
est radicale avantage numéro 1 cramique
al'avantage il est champion du monde
mais en force pure disons pour gagner
des tournois comme celui qu'elle devait
y caser
est-ce que c'est lui qui va gagner il
n'est pas du tout certain il fait
beaucoup de nuls moi je veux je pense
pas qu'il va gagner mes chroniques c'est
une sorte de petrossian moderne en fait
c'est le joueur qui prend peu il perd
très peu a été noire et cherche vraiment
l'égalité pas plus alors ce ton avec
andy les meilleurs ce qui sont là il ya
un an dia topaloff
il ya évidemment krainik et on va
retrouver aussi d
un peu les outsiders à rognan navarra le
tchèque qui est aussi un outsider et par
les jeunes radjabov où il ya que deux
absents il ya que l'écho et yves en
dessous qu qu'on peut dont on peut
regretter l'absence mais il ya beaucoup
de jeunes
ils ont privilégié ils ont raison à mon
avis puisque d'ailleurs la réalité nous
le montrera de labeouf est en tête nous
ils ont eu raison de me convoquer car
yakine radjabov carlo scène et on
regrette on peut regretter que bacrot
sois pas invitée
oui on va relater bah oui dans les voies
a manqué l'année dernière la série de
grands tournois qu'il a eu à jouer et il
a été trop terme des résultats
il avait un virage à prendre il n'a pas
su saisir sa chance mais je pense qu'il
peut rebondir aussi bien bon il a je
sais pas et il lui a manqué quelque
chose pendant l'année 2006 je sais pas
il faudrait peut-être là la vitese
l'envi de gagner peut-être je sais pas
vraiment je ne connais pas bien je peux
pas m'exprimer totalement sûr bacrot
mais bon ce que j'ai vu des coups qu'il
a joué il m'a évidemment déçu parce que
j'ai pas vu un style non plus se dégage
est tellement de son jeu ouais d'accord
et on veut il pas encore travailler
encore très jeune il ya un gros travail
talent il peut pourquoi pas devenir
champion du monde n'est pas exclue à mon
avis il devrait essayer de ne pas trop
écouter les entraîneurs et penser le jeu
d'échecs tout seul oui il a subi une
grosse influence par dorfman bon ça lui
a fait faire des progrès énormes pendant
un certain moment mais arrivée dans le
top 10 mondial je crois qu'il faut plus
compter les terminer sa propre personne
compter que sur soi-même
de toute façon il faut mais qui bâtit sa
propre façon de voir le jeu est sûre en
tenant compte des influences sinon qu'il
a mais mais peut-être s'affirmer
peut-être un peu plus en tant que
personnalité donc de steven coat
horaires topalov on s'aperçoit qu'il n'a
pas fait de compromis sions sur son
style a toujours été aussi agressif à
tout moment de sa carrière je travaille
en salle et ça finit par payer
alors on va tout de suite bien passé à
une des parties de ce grand tournoi et
guy
va mettre en scène peut-être le plus
important protagonistes de ce début de
tournoi c'est radjabov qui alors de
façon il y un peu inattendu quoique bon
il avait gagné cap d'agde un déjà en
finale face à khanaqinne d'ailleurs bon
c'est un trois parties rapides mais
quand même bon c'est aussi un jeune
joueur qui avait battu kasparov autour
de linares il y avait juste
peut-être l'année avant que kasparov
prenne sa retraite il avait il avait
battu dans ça va énerver kasparov
passablement d'ailleurs et là il fait un
super début de tournoi alors ces jeunes
radjabov d'abord il faut dire qu'il est
extrêmement ambitieux je me rappelle un
peu avant je crois d'ailleurs le tournoi
où il avait battu kasparov ça doit être
donc en 2004 à linares
il avait déclaré à l'époque ça m'avait
stupéfait il avait dit kasparov
m'empêche d'être champion du monde
ouais ils bloquent ma carrière il
m'empêche de jouer moi j'aimais le monde
avait pensé que c'était un petit rigolo
et l'avait dit présomptueux arrogant 1
il s'était même rendu assez ridicule et
détestable et là on voit que cette
ambition
une fois positive et sur l'échiquier ce
que ça peut donner c'est extraordinaire
il est prêt à massacrer tout le monde
ouais et à l'air assez là à ce moment il
a quatre points et demi sur cinq
il aurait très bien pu voir cinq puisque
la partie où il a fait nul ils avaient
dames contre touré fou contre car yakine
évidemment le temps est long il n'a pas
encore joué contrôlées une à maya leurs
favoris n'ont pas joué topalov venant
des gradins
mais en attendant c'est vrai qu'ils
apprennent très très bon départ et on va
voir une de ses premières parties qui
effaça alexei shirov voilà on va montrer
cette partie est là on l'a en plus ça
mord moi ça me fait vraiment doublement
plaisir de réaliser deux parties puisque
face à shirov on va retrouver peut-être
aussi ce qui fait peut-être la marque
des grands champions du monde aussi
pause potentiel c'est de pouvoir jouer
l'estonienne et ça fait longtemps qu'on
n'a pas vu des staline au top niveau
oui alors il est un remarquable de voir
que radjabov quand il avait pièce noire
au tournoi de head's et il joue pour
gagner
il joue la dissymétrie comme top alors
vienne compte par l'ofs comme tales of
je pars en ce moment non consenti de
rajab disons que radjabov joue chaque
partie pour la gagner c'est très
différent de la majorité des autres
joueurs du tournoi on a parlé de
cramique on peut même dire qu'un hand
avec thé noir est prudent et qu' il fait
partie des vraiment des exceptions
radjabov de ceux qui blanc ou noir
essayer de gagner chaque partie alors on
y va
maintenant on va passer dans le coeur de
cette émission du jour sur le dos la
corus bank andy avec une des parties de
ce tournoi hollandais 2007 shirov donc
qui reste toujours dans les meilleurs
mondiaux face ça radjabov la nouvelle
nouvelle star est tout jeune à radjabov
puisqu'il a exactement quel âge ils 20
en deux ans je mène deux ans a nié tout
aux jeunes je suis pas si lui-même pas
plus jeune que 22 je crois qu'il faudra
vérifier le exactement son âge et c'est
parti pour shirov qui lui par contre est
un briscard un peuple un joueur affirmé
radjabov ya un joueur en 97 à joueur
parisien qu'il l'avait battu dans un
open je me rappelle est il était fier il
avait dit je garderai la feuille de
partie il avait dédié le roy joint
d'accord à l'open de grande gueule et ne
veut plus le radjabov qui avait 9 10 ans
alors on y va des quatre cavaliers 6 et
ses 4 g 6 pour l'instant donc on peut
rentrer dans une autre une fête mais
après car les c3 c'est le coup fut g7
et alors ça fait très longtemps que au
top niveau dans le top 10 il ya pas eu d
stand yen puisque tout le monde a peur
de la tacc baïonnette oui depuis le
départ de kasparov
il ya quasiment j'avais même kasparov
avait arrêté même qu'espérer jouer plus
croisés avaient trop peur mais notamment
face à cranie mais hélas il subit
quelques défaites contre
d'ailleurs on attend tous peut-être
l'affrontement cramique rajab aux faux
kramnik orale et blanc est-ce que rajab
jours à l'estonienne
alors là ça risque d'être vert de la
voir tellement potasse et je crois qu'il
hésitera ça risque d'être tout à fait
extraordinaire s'il peut se passer alors
que quatre des six de radjabov et on est
dans un geste aliens classique fou aux
deux je suis ravi parce que je suis un
joueur des stades yen alors ça fait très
longtemps qu'on en voyait plus petit
rock cavaliers f3 donc tout ça est très
classique et aux 5 voilà donc ici les
blés noirs ont pas peur de la prise en 5
puisque si sûr c'est cette prise en cinq
ans près après les charges des dames et
la prise du cavalier sûr si on prenait
le pion aux cinq se plaint et noir
peuvent répondre par câble et prend 4
il ne faisait cette attaque le cavalier
ou 5
il ya d'autres possibilités aussi
d'ailleurs voilà donc on va continuer
par petit rock pour les blancs cavaliers
c6 voilà classique on continue la
pression la maintenance ce coup de
cavaliers al'avantage de contrôler la
casse des 4 et de défendre si le pion au
5eme pression sous la pression ici sur
le pion sur l'option des 4 donc ça c'est
classique
on va on va pas trop commenter le début
parce que là il vaut mieux vivre lire un
livre d'ouverture à la limite des 5 et
au lieu des 5 on peut aussi protéger non
par fou de 3 voilà qu'il autre coup si
tu m'en fous et 3 mai dessin qu'on va en
à rendre en rentre dans ce qui ressemble
à l'attack baïonnette kallio 7 et la b4
là c'est la tacc baïonnette
si on rajoute des cas très tôt et on n'a
pas peur avec les blancs c'est kramnik
populariser cette façon de jouer
l'estonienne on n'a pas peur du coup à 5
sur lequel on joue pas évidemment à
trois puisque à prendre b4 et la torah 8
ici cloud la tour un nom qu'on peut pas
reprendre le pion sous peine de perdre
la tournée sur à 5
on joue tout simplement le couffo à
troyes où on prend aussi je crois
voilà ici on prend on prend à 5 qu'on va
voir cavaler h5 de rajab offre donc il
fait il se moque un peu de cette cette
avancée tours 1-2 shirov epson donc ça
c'est le plan un peu classique alors oui
dans le temps on joue à cavalier f4 dans
cette position oui alors au lieu de cinq
qu'est ce qui se peut se passer
d'ailleurs nicolas si les blancs
prennent prenant 8 5
que se passe-t-il on prend avec le fou
on peut prendre avec le pion aussi
peut-être vous avec le pion c'est un peu
plus risqué parce que lecavalier h5
n'est pas protégé mais il ya le cab a
laissé 3 qui va être emprisonné mais on
peut jouer ainsi qu'alléger 5
voilà pour attaquer le pion le cavalier
h5 et en même temps proposé cavaliers au
cices voilà donc
petite subtilité alors f5 calais
j'essaye tout de suite de chiroque donc
il doit un plan aussi classique il fait
pression avec le fouet deux sur le
clavier 5 en même temps ces cavaliers a
vocation à venir sur la case de 6 pour
s'échanger contre le fou s'est vite
souvent dangereux alors il faut dire que
deux jours avant radjabov avec les noirs
avaient déjà joué la même position
contre vente venir oui il avait gagné il
avait gagné aussi tout à fait là ils
sont encore dans la même position que ça
veut dire qu il
il est en train peut-être de démontrer
radio voix qui veut jouer les stalles
yen tourne en quoi il n'a pas peur oui
et puis shirov accepte ça parce qu'il a
dû travailler la partie d'entre eux a
déjà bossé
alors on rapatrie le caillage 5 c'est
logique
voilà pour éviter évidemment la prise
par le fou eu deux et on fait un sens
même temps ça mais précis ça fait la
pression sur le sur le pion aux 4 et la
f3 tout simplement voilà c'est logique
je crois que l'explication explique le
coup tout simplement rouages suit donc
un coup classique euros à suit souvent
on veut recycler un cavalier en a
ensuite voilà le cavalier recettes
parfois elle n'a pas de bonnes gaz
naturel à sa disposition alors on lui en
offre une en bougeant le roi la case
vide d'où il peut rebondir
bref si ce qu'en fera entendre dire
quand celui-là aura bougé cavaliers
aussi donc ça y est c'est l'heure pour
shirov de proposer des changes fou
cavaliers et radjabov le fait fou prend
puis on prend et maintenant caillage
celle qu'on peut revenir la chaîne
puisque le coût est de 3 à boucher la
puissance du du coup d'am-dam fou le
goût est expliquée par les lamas neuf
qui va suivre série se dirige vers
j'essaie ce cavalier pour ensuite
capturé le pion aux crises et il veut
prendre sa piaule 6 alors ils voulaient
blanc en est on fait cette manoeuvre de
cavaliers en réussissent ils ont eu
comme avantage de se donner la case des
5 pour le cavalier c3 le cari c3 en
règle générale ils ont aussi ouvert le
jeu dans le secteur où ils sont amenés à
attaquer c'est à dire les dames et le
centre est en revanche
l'inconvénient c'est que l'opium si
c'est qui
quasiment mort il va être capturé il est
dans un filtre est dans le camp noir on
peut pas défendre facilement difficile à
défendre prix d'un pion ils ont ouvert
le jeu et le rideau blanc c'est de
gagner sur la colonne sait où la colonne
d après l'ouverture du jeu et la
mobilisation du phocéen de la tour e le
centre alors j'ai trois de la part de
schirrhoffen arashiro faveur d'un cahier
leucate qui se dirigent et qui attaque
cissé qui propose un échange de foot
cases noires qui enrobe avantagerait
énormément de coups g7
on n'aurait pas peur du qui ont doublé
puisque le plus ancien que c'est changer
facilement et le fou g7 par contre
dynamiserait les pièces noir voilà en
donnant la paire de fou si on rendrait
la paire de fou fou et si ça y est donc
c'est le plan donc très joli 2e radjabov
tout simplement faux ici si on veut
jouer cavalier g7 est allé prendre le
pion eu six tout simplement et la csn de
shirov saiss et leur bon il profite de
son coupé 4 pour jouer ces 5 et
commencer à affaiblir la chaîne de pions
noirs ici pour essayer de créer des
faiblesses tout simplement
mais il faut bien faire quelque chose le
coup c'est quel sexe et la percée normal
des blancs dans les stades yens voilà
percée classique les la f cap de la part
de radio bof f4 donc la protéger par le
cavalier f5 lacazette car c'est ici que
ça change et c'est ici qu'on l'a on
pourrait jouer g4 qui ferment varier le
roi tomberait dans la partie de
manivelles radjabov avec les cavaliers
g7 et le pion aux six va être pris tôt
ou tard la mêlée radjabov avait recyclé
le cavalier g7 est allé prendre ensuite
le point 6 et il y avait eu un oeil vers
la case des 4 et après ils veulent
autres cavaliers étaient venus en c6 et
donc les cavaliers noirs avaient été
assez actif et finalement il y avait
gagné sur les dames paradoxalement sur
la colonne c'est qu'ils s'étaient
ouvertes en faveur des noirs alors que
dans cette partie c'est très différent
radjabov avait gagné radjabu file staff
et des noirs avec hélas shirov ne veut
pas bloquer le droit tout de suite il
fait roi g23 g2 c'est ça le coup qu'il
avait préparé avant d'affronter radjabov
donc là radjabov lui qu'avait laissé six
voix là et il veut tout simplement
revenir sur casse des 4l son cavalier
très certainement pour en liaison avec
le fouet f6 le pion aux 5 et bien
bloqués un peu les les blancs notamment
la colonne d epuis libère la dame noire
aussi vers le nord pourra aussi
peut-être plus tard jouer sur ses terres
gaudin effectivement comprend des six
comprend des six cas les dessins donc ça
c'est logique car il profite de la belle
case des cinq ou six parce que les
blancs quand même au moins cette occase
et l'accabler des quatre en échanges et
en les noirs aussi une très bonne très
beau carrière des cats et surtout pour
aller capturer pions tout de suite et ça
ça me laisse évidemment aussi
effectivement d'aller prendre le pion le
6 foulée 2 le fait tout de suite tu es
allé prendre 6 radjabov g4 d'être shirov
c'est l'heure pour lui de bloquer les
droits apparemment et la cave alias g7
gouvernance qui est remarquable dans
cette partie c'est qu'à partir de
maintenant on a l'impression que les
noirs sont très mal leurs pièces n'ont
pas d'avenir lesquels elle et noirs sont
enfermés surtout le cavalier g7 mais
l'autre aussi puisque
allez en d4 supposerait détérioration
des pions noirs
et puis les blancs un superbe qui avait
lié au centre le roi blanc autour de lui
c'est bloqué on a vraiment l'impression
que les blancs une position écrasant ce
parce que sur les deux colonnes c et d
vont pouvoir s'imposer pouvoir s'imposer
mais c'est pas si claire apparemment
peut-être cirfa peut-être pas choisi
bons plans aussi en faisant cavale et
profond mais apparemment shirov et gagne
enfin c'est l'impression vraiment que
90% des joueurs de compétition ont tout
de suite en regard de la position
on va voir jusque là la tacle attaque du
côté roy semble un peu arrêté mais on a
toujours possibilité pour les noirs dans
ce type de configuration estonienne de
jouer le coup aussi h5 pour dur pour
ouvrir des lignes aussi au graff le coup
suivant cheer au ficp rend le fou noir
profond noir et le four b2 c'est à ça
que je suis revenue ans en faisant cet
échange va bientôt se réveiller avec un
effet apparemment qui décisive sur le
roi noir ça c'est l'impression qu'on va
avoir mais dans la réalité quand il va
s'agir de chercher les coûts précis pour
attaquer avec les blancs curieusement on
va voir une panouille de l'attak blanche
alors que la taxe noire elle elle va
continuer mais c'est vraiment une partie
étonnant parce qu'apparemment comme ça
les noirs ont les uns foutu alors on va
voir dans tout reprend f6 pour garder la
dame à la défense du pion des six ça
serait une catastrophe si ce pion venait
à tomber puisque le fourbe et de l'or là
deviendrait très fort puisqu'il
attaqueraient la faiblesse cinq dames
d52 shirov donc il veut surgiront très
certainement très simplement augmenter
la pression sur des six taureaux d1
au passage il est vrai que le pion et il
attaque le pion 17 donc dames cette
logique de radjabov à la fois je prépare
un éventuel une éventuelle protection
ici on débite tout en protégeant le pion
bessette
tout est logique tour d un on voit la
logique pour shirov j'attaque le ton et
6 et là tout simplement tour des huit
radjabov tranquille protège champions et
maintenant c'est vrai que c'est pas
facile pour les blancs d'augmenter la
pression sur ce pion
des 6 mai shirov a trouvé une manière
assez raffiné pour mettre la torah un
enjeu il fait d'abord dame à 5 alors
damascène pour shirov provoquent ils
attaquent le puma 7 il provoque bézis b6
maintenant la dame s'est tu protèges
version à sept la dame blanche revient
où il était on se demande à quoi ça a
servi et bien c'est la case c6
maintenant cette case qui va être
accessible pour la tour-blanche tour 6 1
et tours ces six pour faire pression sur
le plan des six on va voir comment ça se
passe tour et fait suite de radjabov on
a l'impression que les noirs en plus ne
font rien pour effet une sorte de perdre
de temps alors ça libère la dame ça
relis les tours et de toute façon les
noirs pourraient toujours peut-être
aussi protéger le camp des six sauts
dans le pire des cas par cas value8 même
si c'est pas si fin évidemment sa part
extrêmement passif torah c'est un donc
logique pour shirov il veut tout
simplement joué tour c6 et augmenté la
pression sur lyon des six est là
maintenant c'est l'heure pour les droits
h5 voilà toujours classique dans les
eaux indiennes
en général c'est les noirs qui attaque
du côté roy anarchy roc n'a pas hésité
longtemps avant de prendre je prends
hashtag parce que si fait h3h trois cas
les rebonds il ya là match 82 ans hk que
les menaces de sa fille trajets trop et
là il ya la menace 100 gr iii et le
curage trois tombes et après le pion gta
doit tomber ça va être terrible est donc
pour pas avoir ce genre de problème
shirov il avait changé les pions parce
que la menace aussi là c'est tout
simplement prendre des cartes mais avec
suivi de 4 et celle suivie de f3 et
cheikh aweys suivi douala une fourchette
ici une fourchette royal bien vu très
belle fourchette royal on va on va
regarder sedran peut-être on va on va
juste la regarder cette possibilité par
imaginant que les blancs joueurs comme
tour ses six escales en forêt pions
projet 4 et sur pions pranger 4 on
pourrait faire f 3 échecs fourchette
fournois donc il faudrait prendre avec
le fou et maintenant la fourchette royal
pouf cavaliers quatre échecs au roi et
attaques de la dame des cinq superbes
alors h 5 g prend 1 102 shirov pour
éviter de leur fille j'ai suivi la
partie en direct et radjabov
passé 25 minutes sur ce coup et au lieu
de faire cavalier prend h5 est tout à
fait jouable ou même pions prend hashtag
pour ouvrir la colonne du marieur il
joue un coup étonnant et joue des
matches quatre dames h4 qui n'est
peut-être pas qui a fait plonger aussi
chez rough trade un des emblèmes de
réflexion elle d'un match 4 est-ce qu'on
se demande ce que veut faire la dame ici
pour l'instant qu'est ce que vient de
faire la dernière peut-être ces noms ne
sait pas tout de suite on va voir de
toute façon on va voir alors pas facile
à ce qu'il fera tout cas la dame se
rapproche du roi c'est l'idée c'est que
si les blancs laisse faire ce qui
d'ailleurs va se produire dans la partie
la dame est passé devant le plonger si
c'est à dire mais ensuite il rage et 5g
cadre avec la verne déjà placé en
achetant déjà posté déjà posté pour
faire des dégâts près du rouge blanc
mais bon giro forêt pu prendre
maintenant angèle 6 alors qu'est ce qui
se passe sur pied un projet 6 pouces et
la justice pour gagner un temps aussi
mais bon ça par exemple imaginons pions
progressis peut-être tours 8
on pourrait aussi jouer et aux epci
saint nicolas pour attaquer en justice
avec un échec
toi et à tours en plus à 1 h 6 peut
avoir du jeu après voilà pour ferme at
il continué donc d'un mach 4 tours 6
donc c'est ça devient quand même un peu
chaud pour shirov du côté du côté droit
mais il continue c'est souvent comme ça
on voit pas encore la manette noire et
durable en dépit et shearer celui ci je
prends ce pion des 6,7 après mon four b2
de prendre 5 ça va être terrible
je vais vite gagné beaucoup de matériel
et là tout de suite c'est l'heure pour
radjabov j'ai cinq ans là là c'est
terrible c'est une vraie cet alien est
en plein dans ces superbes puisque la
menace maintenant c'est tout simplement
g4 avec ouverture des lignes maximale
perron des sacrifices après un tailleur
sur pied un projet quand on peut jouer
encore f3 toujours pareil avec la
fameuse crochète royal donc attention
tout reprendre et 6 seller il faut pas
que chez rough dorment évidemment et
radjabov eh bien ils saluent est égale
évidemment la prison des huit puisque il
reprendrait de la tour et la dame sont
obligés de
quitter la grande colonne puisque le
cahier aussi se protège très bien la
caisse de la caisse des 8
donc j'ai 4 alors ici c'est un peu le
tournant de la partie et j'étais
persuadé que shirov fait une gaffe il a
perdu la partie
mais la position semble gagnante pour
les blancs puisque il aurait dû parlant
de diagonale et c'est ouvert
donc j'ai fait tourner le moteur
banalise et à ma grande surprise je me
suis aperçu que les noirs sont mieux
très racée terrible les noirs sont mieux
contrairement aux apparences la dame
noire seul avec les pions fait plus de
plus de dégâts de des as de dégâts c'est
quoi la vraie menace là parce que si par
exemple si vous avez joué dame prend +1
d'en produire c'est l'impression qu'il
ya beaucoup de coups le roi noir qui est
très mal oui pour l'instant ça tient
pour l'instant ça tient en fait ils
jouent damas trois échecs les noirs
damas trois échecs alors 3g ou h un peu
importe rejoindre 3g
roger m&g trois simples et extrêmement
fort il ya le ya le mat tab rage de
dents d'un mec de maths sans compter les
possibilités d'un proche de j'ai deux
échecs subis de dames 2e dames avec
échec
ça fait très mal ça va vite elle estime
que je l'avais très très vite il faut
quand même faire attention donc super
ben radhia bof j'ai quatre coups superbe
alors il a été proposé ici des coups de
défense du style foulée fin je crois
fouet fin avec l'idée que ce repérage
trois échecs sur damas trois échecs
quand on arrive aux endroits il n'y a
pas le temps de faire un coup de pub oui
il ya aussi rô le courage est inquiété
mais dans ce cas là il se passe
apparemment
et bien tout simplement nicolas qu il
semblerait qu'on perde une pièce puisque
tout reprend des 6 es sûr d'en prendre
et si tout simplement tour des huit
puisque maintenant la tour est derrière
oui mais des sacrifices attention la
dame protège très bien la dame protège
tibias très bien des vies mais il ya des
contraintes impossible encore des
anneaux mais rien
donc à ce problème là aussi donc c'est
passé ne passaient pas valables le mp3
g1 et suroît j'ai un autre possibilité
avait encore g3 ton cou qui a l'air très
fort mais oui mais sur le coup j'ai
trois puisque on voit pas comment on
empêche dame prend h2 puisque même si on
bouge le pire on prendrait le pion et si
on fit h 30 g3s pranger 3 et non c'est
vrai c'est pas mal non c'est terrible
donc peut-être c'est déjà foutu
c'est terrible on va voir quand même
comment shirov lui qui est quand même
bon mais pas le premier venu à essayer
de jouer la défense il a tout simplement
confirmé pris le car il ya 6
c'est-à-dire qui donne la dame si rob
qui est un roi du sacrifice qui est
brillant quand il attaque il n'a pas pu
s'empêcher celle naturelle qui revient
au galop d'attaqué défense s'est
sacrifié lui mais c'est pas tout
reprendre et 5 et la sueur pas voulu
jouer tourage six échecs et après roy g8
un coup subtil poussé katsav est à
présent toutes les pièces blanches sont
à l'attaqué le voile avec mater mais il
n'a pas calculé assez loin et en fait
ils se retrouvent c'est une variante
maintenant forcés ou il a une qualité en
moi la fin juin alors on va voir comment
radjabov maintenant transforme cette
sacrifice de dames erronée il fait quand
price trois échecs roi achats et
maintenant tout simplement cavale et
prend 1,5 avec l'idée que sur fou prend
tout rond comme ça le roi a au moins une
case sinon il y en a des parts voilà n'y
avait pas de case et en même temps il
fait une menace immense de louer cavale
et j'ai trouvé dans la tour blanche et
il gagne la tour blanche dont j'ai un
échec et la cavale et j'ai trois échecs
ça y est voilà c'est le coup alors oui
on a le droit à trois échecs au roi de
suite tout projet trois échecs oui tout
à fait
échec les chèques reçus et contre échecs
et maintenant puis on prend juste si on
prend g3 donc ils laissent noir en prime
il laisse les avants emprise ainsi
claude j'aime sacrifices
la partie cette fois dix par des noirs
secure mais en fait oui menace parce
qu'il ya une menace de faire dame c'est
ça on va voir une combinaison forcé en
fait il aurait pu prendre aussi le la
tour en premier mais non il a mis en
échec
là ils épargnent à wil était en échec
qu'il était en effet tout à fait donc
tout reproche 4 est quasiment forcé un
nom il peut prendre on ne peut pas la
donne en fait que peut prendre la tour
ça change pas grand chose
il préfère garder le fou qui combine ans
ça change pas parce que les noirs faire
une dame a ensuite avec les voilà c'est
ça c'est que le fou contrôle aurait pu
la case f1 c'est à dire que sur la même
variante évidemment il y aurait pions et
fin dames avec matt derrière on peut la
montre et d'ailleurs si on fait fou
prend tour ça serait une erreur parce
qu'on enlève le fou de la protection des
cases f1 même si ça paraît bon puisqu'on
fait échec ont fait 3 g7 tout simplement
attaque la tour et bien sûr tout reprend
dame kikai le seul coup et bien tout
simplement j'ai deux échecs roi g1 est
maintenant f2 échec
protégé par la touriste fuite le roi ne
peut plus faire autre chose que prendre
le pion g2 et maintenant on fait une
dame échec et c'est matt après roy
gérard davet trois matches voilà donc
superbe décidé massivement une
combinaison d'estienne absolument
géniale et je prends g3 3,4 et
maintenant c'est l'heure aussi pour le
même type de sacrifices à la différence
près qu'il s'agit de des clous et c'est
pour finalement non à la fin il faut
tout avec la culture plus avec l'ue et
la turquie va asséner le coup décisif
alors j'ai deux échecs
roger à f2 échec maintenant roi g2 et on
remarquera que maintenant le fait que le
four soit resté en c4 est important
puisque on contrôle la casse de
promotion de la dame sall empêchent par
asia beau de faire quand même dame échec
et après fou prend f1 de faire tout
simplement tour des deux échecs pour
récupérer le four b2 est resté avec on
le voit tour contre tours et tour ici
contrefout donc une qualité pour justin
pions pour les blancs ce qui est souvent
insuffisant on va voir d'ailleurs et les
tournois sont très actives
les réseaux de menthe au roi blanc c'est
pour ça qu'il ya une très vite le parti
orange et trois tours prend b2 attaque
le fou et attaque le pion des quatre
pouces et quatre échecs projet cette
fougue et 3 pour empêcher la perte du
qui ont des quatre maintenant tour b1
avec l'idée d'un coup tout simplement
échec pour h3 et tour h3 matt 3g 2 pour
shirov et maintenant tour c'est 8
il veut créer des réseaux ferrés fnac en
quelques coups
il veut jouer pour ces trois là mais je
tour ces trois pour bloquer ici le roi
et ensuite au tmb 2 et après deux tours
c'est un acte relève trois pour shirov
tour ces trois échecs quand même
roger 4 et il referme la boîte avec
touré fin voilà on veut pas laisser
partir ce roi on veut continuer à créer
des réseaux de maths et après roanne 5
airwave 6 eh bien ils abandonnent shirov
il va avoir du mal ils ont invité les
maths et de toute façon la qualité est
trop forte le four b3 est quasiment
obligé de rester en b 3 sous peine de
perdre tous les pions et puis on
remarquera que la tour blanche est
enfermé et la tour blanche est enfermé
c'est à dire qu'il va pouvoir même mot
radjabov et proposer des changes de
tours aux six gagnants tout simplement
avec avec sa qualité plus superbe partie
de radia bof c'est magnifique parce que
il ya deux sacrifices de l'homme dans la
partie d'un côté et de l'autre
et puis surtout cette façon de faire h 5
puis on prend pions et là de faire un
coup tranquille on va courir tout à fait
inattendue superbe super héros et
réhabilite les stalles yen au plus haut
niveau à verser à la casse par obs et
une install yen comme envoyer kasparov
et ça l'est dans les années depuis
fischer ont dit que les champions du
monde doivent tous avoir joué les stades
yens
la musicienne quoi ils rappellent
beaucoup car pop n'ont jamais vu de sa
vie un quart va pas jouer il a joué
contre on a eu sinon mental qui ont joué
c'est parce qu'ils ne jouaient pas non
plus fichiers rar kasparov corse
nouilles en fin n'a pas été champion du
monde c'est vrai mais
sinon les championnats précédents mais
malkin ce n'était pas à la mode à son
époque donc destin viennent c'est un
oiseau noir ce niveau la très belle
analyse donc évidemment continuer à
suivre ce tournoi chorus donc on va se
retrouver nicolas pour la prochaine
émission
d'accord donc comment tu vois la suite
de ce tournant corrige toujours radjabov
en tête
l'iphone quelque chose radium enfin un
début de tournoi favorable au niveau des
appariements parce que j'y joue contre
dix on l'a les outsider ce ne sont pas
les favoris
anhorn cramique et topalov qui va
affronter donc ils engrangent il
engrange en ce moment les points contre
contre des joueurs ils ont plus tendre
que les favoris dont on line permis
voilà évidemment faudra suivre
évidemment le parcours de topalov
anachronique qui sont pas loin derrière
et qui eux ont l'expérience de gérer les
tournois sur le long terme
voilà puis topalov aussi est capable
d'aligner beaucoup de gains à la fidh
est capable de remonter comme il l'a
fait l'année dernière plusieurs tournois
qu'il avait mal débuté il les a
finalement gagné quand même en a la rage
ligne en trois quatre victoires de suite
tout à fait tout à fait donc très très
fort sur les fans pour moi à toi pas le
voilà donc c'était cette émission
diagonale tv spéciale chorus la première
il y en aura d'autres évidemment
poursuivre ce grand tournoi mondial l'un
des plus 2 3 1 plus grand du monde avec
linares dortmund chorus donc c'était
avec nicolas giffard et je vous donne
rendez vous mais pour une prochaine
émission sur des modèles tv merci merci
nicolas au revoir
oh